here's morgan in the word sir pierce
morgan in the world could you describe
ps morgan in one word are you on the
phone to your mum do you know who piers
morgan is can ask you to describe piers
morgan in one word legend legend for a
man who has fans across the world we had
to get opinions from across the world to
see if anyone actually liked him so
we've sent cameras all the way from
australia to america and up and down
these great british isles to ask people
to describe peers in one word
irritating
spot on awesome he could lose a couple
of pounds clever
problematic entertaining narcissist
annoying honest very bald just a bit of
a
forthright
hello guys could you describe pierce
morgan in one word
piers morgan in a word come on let's get
a bit faster than this fancy outspoken
i think he's hilarious to be honest
ballsy adorable obnoxious abrupt
fantastic brilliant i love him
opinionated fantastic [ __ ] brave
questionable
could you describe piers morgan in one
word for me i'm french i'm sorry lapis
morgan ciolo television meghan markle
woke
that kind of guy you know how are you
doing i'm not pierce morgan myself
opportunist og judgmental liberal
curious funny jerk controversial fake
loving ignorant yeah different talented
opinionated political he sees us as it
is
contradictory piers morgan
in einvert can that's why yes you can
creative exuberant maybe mean p-l-a-i-n
polarizing bad attitude
concise who is pierce morgan though
brutal cunning hypocrite entertaining
get you to describe pierce morgan in one
word could i ask you to describe piers
morgan in one word centric interesting
fabulous truthful charming rash
fascinating
controversial sexy from manchester to
minnesota la to london we've heard what
people have to say about pierce morgan
but now pierce it's your turn tune in
from the 25th of april for pears morgan
uncensored